by the Department of
Labor on
um House Bill
48 I'm sorry not House Bill 48 House
Bill 232 so uh we have a two new members
today uh
folks representative stab from
Manchester is is now replacing uh Josh
Adent and Madam clerk um we have a fill
in today representative Cole oh great is
filling in so I just want to make sure
you
have we have filling in
for um I'll remember his name in a
second uh Mason James Mason thank
you so we're going to start with the
Pledge of Allegiance Michael kahill
would you please lead
us United States of
America for stands
Nation
indivisible andice for
all as you know we have four bills to go
through
today House Bill 190 232 182 and 82 and
there have been some amendments and um
some of these amendments you have not
had the opportunity to review very well
at all and I respect that so at any time
representative Sullivan and I um feel it
it's inappropriate to to vote on
something and bring it up because
there's not been an appropriate time to
review the Amendments we will recess uh
if we can for a short period of time if
not we will recess to the following
Thursday to resolve
anything right we did the best we could
with
OS
um House Bill 232
FN uh as you know is retained had a
number of subcommittees and a lot of
things were done um meetings were had
with the subcommittee as well as the
Department of Labor obviously many of
you were not here for that and we felt
it was appropriate um to hear from the
Department of Labor
um as to some of the discussions that
have been had representative
Sullivan say that about say that
accurately yes okay so at this point we
will introduce the Department of
Labor please come to
the podium and um the floor is yours on
House Bill uh 232 I'll I I'll um any
questions anyone have just raise your
hand as usual and I will uh recognize
you to ask any questions of the
department right floor is
yours went
back my apologies technology is not my
strong suit um I'm Dan Daniel Albert I'm
the Deputy Commissioner of the
Department of Labor um I'll allow my
counterpart to introduce himself I'm
Wesley Gardner director of the Workers
Compensation Division for the New
Hampshire Department of
Labor so the department has uh reviewed
the proposed um language relative to uh
the um to the house bill um and I'm I I
believe attorney Gardner who was former
general counsel for the department has
had um the most dealings with um I'm
going to let him give a bit of an
overview about the uh amendments that
are on the table uh as well as um some
background as to the Department's
involvement um in reviewing the
matter just a moment please represent
Solan just to save you some time you you
said amendments plural um the uh only
amendment that has been distributed is
the amendment that U um uh represents
option two forg forgive me I was
thinking in the context of the the the
various conversations that have occurred
that's that's I just didn't want to have
you go through something that no one's
ever going to see no wor I appreciate
the clarification thank
you so yes so relative to what was uh
previously termed option two um
essentially what this would do is allow
the department to use Ru making and
would direct the department over I
believe a three-year period to
promulgate rules that are at least as
effective as OSHA section
1910 um which is for general duty uh
sorry General construction I believe um
again so this would be through rule
making that we would do this um and this
was as I understand it kind of a
compromise to the initial bill that
you're all aware of from
232 that would allow stakeholders to
have a say in this um and forego the
overall adoption of section 1910 because
there were some issues that were brought
to the table um I can say um at the last
committee meeting one of the major
issues that came up that I think a lot
of people are interested in is
unfortunately if we were to wholesale
adopt section
1910 um there'd be certain pieces that
are required to meet OSHA standards the
major um example that was given by
director roas um last two weeks ago I
apologies not last week was the exiter
town hall um which has some fire doors
that Upon Our review when we went there
recently for a safety inspection would
not comply with section 1910 were we
just to adopt the OSHA language so again
this bill is intended for the Department
to review the 1910s and do it for lack
of a better term the New Hampshire way
um with input from the legislature input
from the stakeholders and input from
other agencies because Upon Our review
of this we did find out that certain
state agencies municipalities had some
very genuine concerns that they'd have
to replace some very expensive equipment
um and might kind of bleed into what
would be an unfunded mandate at the end
of the day um so that's kind of the
overarching um bill that we're left with
now um again I know we had initially
talked uh several years back about a
state plan so that's not this and I like
to just clarify so everyone's aware this
is not a state plan there will be no
federal funds involved in this um and
there will be need to be um some
additional safety inspectors as well
because what we would anticipate doing
is while this is rolling out while we're
prating rules uh we would anticipate a
lot of the stakeholders coming to us
asking can you do a review of our
facilities make sure that we're in
compliance tell us where we might have
holes so we can get ahead of this
because again we understand that a lot
of these stakeholders will have to
generate funds whether that's through
taxes or other mandates um so again we
would expect essentially a consultancy
program to be in place as well where one
we would be doing Outreach but also we'
be Fielding calls from the stakeholders
and doing more audits than we normally
do as it is we have two full-time safy
inspectors and a position for a third um
but again so we would have to expand
that program a little bit and obviously
happy to take any questions on any of
what was just
said representative
Sullivan couple things that uh I think
might might be added for clarification
um the
um there were some concerns expressed
about uh employers needing to add on um
additional expert staff to uh to do do
some reviews and I think what you just
said about the consultancy program um
should allay some of that concern in
that the department is going to take on
the role of assisting Employers in in
making the transition to the um um the
the new standards um
the another thing that it's it's a bit
in the weeds um but something came up in
the last couple days in that there is a
concern
that
uh new new things like the coid um uh
standards um could crop up over the
years and be um and the employers would
be confronted with those things um um as
OSHA adopts them I think it's important
to note that um letter U which is an
exception is the coid standard we are
not adopting that in addition the
chairman um insisted that we also not
adopt the placeholder alphabet pieces um
and um I'm glad he insisted that because
essentially it you know takes away the
concern that um something coid like
might happen two years 10 years you know
20 years from now and they'll grab
another one of those letters and um come
up with some some new standards to fit
the uh the issue at the time we we would
be in a position to say that's a
standard we need let's let's go for it
um but we wouldn't have to um we would
be in the same position as we are right
now with Co so
um there was some care taken to make
sure that we um protected employers as
best we could um I would also uh uh add
in that there is um an authority granted
in this uh Amendment uh for the
Department to determine that um uh
certain standards in the ocean 1910 um
uh list are not applicable to public
sector employees or Employers in and
employees in uh in New Hampshire and
they would be able to not Draft rules to
uh reflect uh um standards that have
nothing to do with um our you know our
workers here um so um and I guess I'd
further like to point out that what we
did was very intentional when we said um
we asked the department um to create a
transition plan that would be workable
for the department and for employers um
and um and I think you did a fantastic
job and I appreciate work um I'm I'm a
believer that if you want something done
right let let the experts weigh in um
and I believe that's what we've done
here and
um I'm uh I'm pleased with the evolution
of this process four years ago there was
a bill that would have just that would
have created the state
plan that then evolved into a um study
committee which made a recommendation of
adopting the 1910 standards and that's
where we were headed forward with this
we then had the retained bill because
employers wanted to weigh in they did
over the month of September and October
and we used that
input I'll say the department used the
input credit where it's do um Department
used that input to create this um at
least effective at least as effective
language that allows um the Department
of Labor to um use common sense in
figuring out how best to apply this
another example that was brought up
during those hearings was the department
of um um Environmental Services
indicated that they they have some
um uh air quality testing equipment um
that is very expensive as you said um
also very
effective however it's built in Europe
and because of that it does not um meet
all of the ocean um certification
standards there's nothing wrong with the
equipment it
simply doesn't you know cross the tees
and out the eyes um this allows the
department to say that equip equipment
is absolutely fine it's going to work
just fine there are no safety issues um
and we're going to prove it um so again
where this is evolved to I think is um a
win-win for um for those of us who want
to see um safety standards you know it's
important to point out that
what what adopting this amendment does
is it fills in the many many gaps that
currently exist in the safety standards
fills fills it in in a New Hampshire
friendly way but it fills them in um
and I I kind of want to stop you for a
second I let you go for a while here um
you have your you're GNA have your time
to to okay okay Joe just wrap it up and
we're going to have some more questions
for these folks but go ahead I have my
say um we're we're here right now we
having questions for the Department
representative McKenzie thank you
um you raised the issue uh all at least
I heard you say uh the unfunded
mandate um and currently the law has
this law has already been created the
safety standard uh law has already been
created
theoretically if and tell me if I'm uh
wrong there are a couple of ways we
could have
gone you have the authority to
promulgate rules under the
department but it was the process we
have now we thought was more
comprehensive it it gives you more
Direction it um so how when you talk
about unfunded mandates if that would to
come up again uh can you explain that uh
as to what what that would mean given
that you already have the authority to
do this it's already in the law well so
I think the key difference in what's
already in the law and what is being
proposed today is while we do have rul
making Authority it's obviously limited
to what is in 277 um we can't just start
expanding it you know there is uh I want
to say essentially like ladders
scaffolding medical kits maybe a handful
of other pieces in there um but that's
kind of what our rul making Authority is
limited to to expanding that to explain
exp in what those standards should be um
what this would do though is we'd be
looking to the 1910s which obviously as
we're all aware by now is much more
expansive goes into a lot more detail
there so I think that's the key
difference between what we currently
have in place um so again we wouldn't if
we were to keep what we had in place we
wouldn't just be able to say be directed
to promulgate rules and then just start
essentially doing um legislative rul
making um and adding in pieces that are
not part part of the
277 if that makes
sense thank
you any other questions for the
Department representative
Granger uh so would this proposal allow
them to make rules uh for public sector
employees that uh in any way are not
described in Ocean 1910 so for instance
if uh if uh the Department of Labor
wanted people to wear masks or they had
to maintain social distancing or any of
the other nonsense we've seen over the
past several years would this allow them
to do that no in the sense that it is
limited to the 1910s and the ru making
Authority is to make sure that our
standards are at least as effective as
the 1910s we could not go into anything
else obviously as chairman infantine had
pointed out and representative Sullivan
that we had carved out subpart U which
was the coid portion the only caveat
that I would set forth there is while
I'm not aware of any coid related items
in the other subp parts of course
there's you know pieces of masks or
something but those as my understanding
are are related to the actual work being
done so it's not a coid um piece um so
it' be much more like um you know if
you're doing some work that uh some dust
particles might be coming off of that
the oosha standard says wear a mask but
again that's not you know I think your
question's relative to co and other kind
of mandates like that again subpart U is
very specific to co so there there are
some mandates um or you know laws or
rules in 1910 relative to mask but not
coid other than subp
partu thank you you're welcome I'm going
to answer a question that I think is
going around here so o ocean 1910 has 26
Parts A through Z right you subpart U
had to do with coid type things that has
been removed X and
Y are blank a few of them are blank so
we wanted to make sure that those were
removed so if OSHA chose to add
something to those we wouldn't be
automatically obligated to them those
are empty spaces within the 26 letters
of the alphabet where they could add
some things so if you wonder why we've
excluded some of these things that's why
some of them one was coid related issues
and one has just nothing they're just
placeholders so that's what you
understand when we start saying subpart
you and whatever what that all
means represent a
proud thank you um regarding ocean how
they deal with how they put things under
letters under 1910 and everything else
would there be anything stopping OSHA
from Sally using this as an example but
it could be broader moving section U to
be now section a sub paragraph one um or
doing other reorganizations like that
could that could have un effects that
are at least from where we're sitting
here today we would view them as
unexpected so I can't say 100% because
to be honest with you I don't know
OSHA's Ru making um on the federal level
what I can say though is I think it
would be quite a leap for them to take
one a full subpart um I think your
question's well founded in the sense
that they very well could add some
pieces to other sub parts that were
adopted here um I think the key piece of
this legislation really comes down to
again we're not just wholesale adopting
this and taking exactly what they're
saying because they do do yearly updates
and it's something that we as the
department if this passes we'll have to
look into to make sure it's at least as
effective but we're not doing the
wholesale adoption it is going through
rul making with public notice public
hearing so everyone can have input um to
include the legislature to include the
stakeholders so again to your question I
I cannot not imagine that they would be
able to take an entire subpart and put
it into another another subpart that
would be encompassed here that being
said though yes I believe that they
could make more robust standards to um
you know add pieces to that given that
the coid um standards are in subp partu
I think it would be a little odd if they
started putting those into other places
CU these subp parts are very specific to
types of equipment of work um so it just
wouldn't seem relevant to me that they
would do that but again caveat being I
don't know exactly how they do it on the
federal level as I reles to rule
making follow
up um I
guess how would it work if a subpart
that we did incorporate referenced a
subpart we didn't say for example you
know they went through every letter that
they have there and say this is how
section U apply applies to when this
work is being done and you know it may
look like that's in conflict with
Section U and this is how you resolve
that conflict and just all those mess of
inter relationships how would that get
resolved yeah that's a fair question I
do think that this was kind of addressed
through um section four of the proposed
language which does state that the
commissioner shall have authority to
determine if standards are inapplicable
to employers and unnecessary to
implement um so again the department has
a level of discretion here to determine
if there are pieces of the subp parts
that are just that don't work for New
Hampshire they're not applicable and
they're unnecessary so I think in that
case it's a piece that we would be able
to look at and say that this is really
not necessary because we specifically in
this example of Co we specifically
Exempted subp part U um so we would see
if there are pieces of it that through
the Incorporated reference might have
relevance to what we're actually looking
for but again we would we would look
look at the end of the day to the fact
that subpart U was specifically Exempted
so um for that reason I think that's how
this bill actually um ensures that
that's not going to be an issue in the
future thank you of course
representative seaworth and
representative
Granger thank you Mr chairman um I'd
like you to clarify something I think I
heard you said earlier and kind of to
paraphrase um you said that your
existing rul making Authority
is
limited to the rules that have already
been promulgated and I'd like you to
explain that further the authorization
for those rules to me seemed somewhat
Broad in that uh
2771 which is what you make the rules
according to um says anything that's
dangerous to safety or health of
employees so it would seem to me that if
you discover a new danger that isn't in
the existing rules you do have existing
Authority could you close that so yeah
that's that's a fair question um and I
think that's something that's been a
kind of a point of contention throughout
this as well too is do we have the
authority to do that um and I think what
we have found is yes to your point we
could do a little bit but you know we
really need a basis for this and I think
it's really difficult for us to say
through rule making that as you said you
know we notice something that's
dangerous but yet the legislature did
not see fit to put any of that even an
inkling of that you know say it's fire
doors or something like that we have
nothing uh concerning fire doors
whatsoever in the 277 so again I think
we kind of run into the potential issue
of legislating through rule um and the
push back with that so um yes so thank
you for the question to clarify um that
that's kind of more where I was going
with it I do think that there is there
is a potential that we could do some rul
making and I think that was an option
that was kind of discussed at the last
committee meeting but we'd be I I would
say we'd be incredibly limited and we
would also expect to receive a fair bit
of push back that you know we're we're
legislating at the end of the day um so
I think that was kind of the concern and
that's why you know we have the intro
paragraph that looks to the 1910s for
guidance because that was another piece
that came up routinely is what are we
looking at for guidance here if it's not
our own rules or our own laws and again
if we're looking at something else using
a basis of say it's OSHA another state
that they're doing this I think that
kind of tends to bleed into legislating
through Ru making so that was the
concern there thank you representative
Granger followed by representative
kale uh so we uh were discussing uh the
issues of uh sort of aiming at the rules
of
1910 um and that leads to certain
problems that I and him might brought up
would it not make sense just to Peg it
to a specific year and just say the the
ocean 1910 rules of the Year
2023 in the actual legislation and then
in the future as they get updated if
they get updated in a way that's
significant or important then the
legislator can adopt legislature can
adopt that uh in the future I could see
that being as a fair compromise I I I
don't see a reason we couldn't do that
um and and I I think it's a point well
taken that if we have a piece that's
static and time then we all kind of
generally know exactly what is coming in
the next three years as we promate
rules thank you representative
kale thank you Mr chair um as I
understand this correctly the private
sector is regulated by OSHA and we're
just changing it to extend it to the
public sector workers
correct yes in the sense that um we're
not really extending all of Osha 1910 is
only one of the Parts
followup good all right so then uh and
and we're doing the New Hampshire 603
version so that you will be aiming at
making them as effective but not but not
a copy of the 1910 regulations yes
that's correct because one of the
overarching concerns I think we heard
and is well founded is that um you know
the 1910s I believe is you know 1100
pages when you print it out um and
there's a lot of minutia in there um and
it can be overbearing for for not just
for the stakeholders but I think you
know for it would be overbearing for us
to implement to a point because you know
we have to have our safety inspectors
trained on this it takes time so again
the intent being that it's at least as
effective and we're looking at those
standards without having to go into you
know it can be a couple of paragraphs
rather than 20 pages on scaffolding and
we say this is at least as effective as
the OSHA regulations and gets us as safe
as the OSHA regulations and again as
much more digestible for the
stakeholders and the public one one more
no follow up thank you very much all
right so um one of the things that one
that brought us here was the fact of of
a public sector worker being injured and
not having it investigated uh after the
fact is that something that would be
addressed if if we do this so this would
just be the standards at the end of the
day I will say the other piece of that
as I testified to earlier is the intent
would also be for us to have a more
robust safety program in the sense that
we would have consultancies we would
have a safety manager we would have
other safety officers so in that sense
you know we would have more uh bandwidth
to go out and do these checks to do
audits um to make sure that places are
safe um and you know more investigations
at the end of the day thanks very much
representative McKenzie then
representative
Sullivan
yeah I have kind of a twoie question
microphone a little
closer I have uh I have kind of a two-
pie question the first one relates to
the progression of the law which moved
the number from five to
15 so when you move that number up in
terms of who is required to file who is
required to have safety and health
programs in their in their facilities do
you have any sense of how many people C
out you're saying for the um joint Loss
Management committee and the safety
programs I do not I I I wouldn't want to
try and fashion a guess honestly um so
I'm not 100% sure I mean I'm sure as
we're all aware though a lot of
businesses in New Hampshire are small
businesses and more than likely below 15
and probably a good chunk that are in
that five to 15 range um but again I I
do not have that data
unfortunately and then the second part
if I could y uh
um so I would like you to speak to the
question of
discretion and there is
currently uh as what I can see um just a
uh gives a commissioner a lot of
authority gives you a lot of authority
to determine you know what goes in and
what doesn't go in I mean we can
certainly petition uh to change the
rules that's we have that we have that
uh we can do that but speak to the
discretion and how those decisions you
think will be made as to what gets in
and what doesn't let you say discretion
as it relates to the rul making piece of
the bill yeah I mean yeah so so again
you know the at least is effective is
something we actually did pull from OSHA
language um because State Plans by and
large they do have a carbon copy of the
ocean regulations because it's frankly
simpler the other option that you can go
with is at least as effective meaning
what it says it's at least as effective
the problem that a lot of the uh States
hav gone with that as I understand it is
it requires a back and forth with OSHA
to determine on OSHA's basis if it's
leas is effective so again that's
something we pulled from there um and to
your question it is there is a decent
amount of discretion there I would say
um of what piece we would keep out what
we would keep in um you know if it
relates to measurements what is that I
think what we would be doing is through
the public hearing process making sure
the stakeholders are involved so we know
like you know boots on the ground beyond
that we would have our safety inspectors
before we're doing this Ru making and
while we are while we're doing the ru
making we would have them actually in
the field seeing how does this affect
people what you know what's safe they
would we would be all doing some
research so we would just the by and
large we would be informed by one what
the OSHA standards are themselves two
reports through OSHA three our own
safety inspections four the stakeholders
ERS and five honestly I think the
legislature as well too because I think
there's a vested interest in a lot of
members of this committee and I think a
piece of this bill was so um everyone
including members of this committee
could have a say when we do come up with
Ru making to say you know I I've done my
own research and I think that we need
this piece of it um so to that point you
know again it's it is Broad you're
correct in that sense um but we've be
using all of those tools all of those
resources to inform our decision I
believe you know and and uh much like
anything else the the longer we go
through that process I would say the
better it gets for everybody because we
all have an understanding of it great I
terrific answer thank you very much
you're welcome representative
Sullivan as a followup to representative
kahill's uh question about
investigations is isn't it true that a
few years ago we did pass a bill that
tightened up the um uh need for
reporting and investigations in the
cases of serious injuries and deaths on
the job yes that is correct thank you
seeing no other
hands going once going
twice thank you very much I appreciate
it uh I would ask you if you wouldn't
mind hanging around a little bit just in
case there's some things that come up
all
right I'm going to move into our
schedule and open the hearing on House
Bill 170 FN relative to duration of
unemployment benefits representative
seaworth oh excuse me
avalani yeah 19 190
FN thank you m thank you Mr chairman I
move
itl motion on the floor is itl do I hear
a second second by representative
seaworth represent balani you're uh
recognized to speak to your motion thank
you Mr chairman um this bill is a little
bit unworkable at this moment in time
and I think a another year to look at it
is in order thank
you all right there's been a motion made
and second in any
discussion seeing none a motion on the
floor is inexpedient to legislate I want
to make sure the clerk is ready here and
then she will call the role
understanding that representative
Cole and
representative she's on there stop okay
all right good you're already on there
representative all right
cool all right uh no other discussion
representative the motion on the floor
is I excuse me R Clark the motion on the
floor is itl please call the rule Vice
chair seaworth yes rep avalani yes rep
Prout yes rep love yes rep Boyd yes rep
Cole yes rep ccom yes R drgo yes R
Granger
no ranking M Sullivan yes rep
barudi rep Cahill yes rep D sylvestra
yes rep Susi yes rep buard yes rep
McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes rep L
Lair yes rep stab yes Mr chair
yes that is 19 to
one any objection to consent
agenda I
object all right you have an objection
those on the regular calendar I'm going
to
skip
repr can I have a word on the next
one
no
two things want
y representative since you are uh uh you
must provide a Minority Report okay all
right thank
you trying to skip around for ease here
folks um House Bill 182 FN prohibiting
discharge of volunteer firefighters or
volunteer uh emergency medical
technicians uh from other employment I
am turning this over since the amendment
is mine uh Mr Vice chairman would you
please chair this uh bill because I
really don't think it's appropriate for
me to be the chair and present my own
Amendment very well uh so I'll look to
you for a motion
then Define my
motion I move ought to pass on Amendment
H excuse me amendment
2023-24
z4h is there second second moved and
seconded uh will you speak to your
Amendment please
thank you as all us
recall we had a bill in front of us to
allow volunteer firefighters to not be
reprimanded or fired for um being late
to their job because they were attending
to an emergency and we got mired in all
kinds of different things about when
they could leave work when they could
not leave work when they were allowed
when they were not then we had the um
when we had some of the um retained uh
sessions these uh representative wolf
who was the sponsor of the bill said I
want the same rights that the ambulance
drivers currently have which really
States if you are on the way to your uh
place of of work and you you either
witness or come across an emergency you
must W render assistance and and do what
you need to do and you cannot be
reprimanded or or uh fired for doing so
and I've done the same thing here for
firefighters um and if you look
online if I can find which
line I can't find what
line
it is line 10 and
11 they witness or come upon while in
route to a place of
employment that is what has been
added and I removed the uh part that uh
on the original bill which kind of gave
a
definition um which really removed the
ability um the the whole thing about
um leaving your office leaving your
place of business
that seemed to be the desire of the
sponsor um and that is what I have
done and again uh representative
Sullivan since this was presented uh to
everyone just now if it is your
desire to
um postpone this to another date that
would be acceptable I will leave it up
to you in
your
group I would say for the time being
Let's uh keep going and see where we we
land the possibility we may want to take
a short caucus but let's uh I guess can
I launch into a question Mr
chair go ahead thank you um as I
recollect during our um discussion of
the retain Bill we we were looking at
some existing um an existing statute
that dealt with the emergency um um
medical Tech techicians and um is is
what we're looking at right now that uh
that language with the firefighters
added
in would you ask the question one more
time sure um I remember finding a
statute during our um discussion earlier
of the retain
bill in that statute um provided pretty
much exactly what what representative
wolf was looking for for as I recollect
emergency medical
technicians um and the thought was just
add the firefighters in and we're there
is that indeed what has been
done yes and no you're talking about
section RSA
153a
and I'm trying to find the exact
subsection where we took this from to
try to copy it
so it was not going to be possible to
add this to 153 because this 153
is emergency medical and Trauma Services
okay okay really didn't fit but I will
would like to at least show
you
exactly what the wording is so you can
review
it and everyone has 153a out in front of
them
no and
FY all right Brian where is it
here I had a dog tag dog AED here to
find
it Well you guys are going to have to
bear with me while I find
153 while you're looking frankly my
concern was that we would put it in the
wrong part of the law the fact that it's
been moved is a good thing now but I
want to find the exact sentence so we
can have let me start from the beginning
I I'd rather it be the exact thing M um
representative Sullivan
so 153
a17
two that's liability it's different
Sullivan yes if I might read please do
I'm reading 153
a17 Roman numeral 2
okay and I know you're looking at it
there so for everyone
else's no license emergency medical care
provider who in good faith attempts to
render Emergency Medical Services
authorized by the this chapter at any
emergency scene while in route to a
place of employment shall receive any
form of reprimand or penalty by an
employer as a result of late arrival in
the place of
employment
okay thank you further questions I
didn't see that
R um yeah if I could just follow up
um
again I I think it's appropriate that
that language be moved into the right um
part of the statute um I guess my
question is um do the emergency medical
technicians are they now um uh cited in
two different U places in our statutes
275 and
153 I I believe they're two different
things 153a has to do
with I believe it's mostly uh ambulance
uh and EMTs whereas
275a volunteers believe has volunteer
fire department and emergency medical
technicians so deal volunteers could
there be a lapse excuse me could there
be a um overlapping yes which is why I
let tried to make the language exactly
the
same you can't put the volunteer
firefighters into the EMTs and you can't
put the EMTs on the volunteer
firefighters okay thank
you other questions or
comments all
people uh representative Sullivan are
you okay with taking a vote on this
amendment at this
time I think I think we'd like to take a
quick caucus just make sure we're on the
same page okay
um 10 minutes
you
long not more than all right we'll
suspend for five minutes to a recess for
five minutes to allow uh um
caucus all right so yours isn't going to
work I
don't
my apologies uh having uh reconvened the
hearing are there any further questions
or points of
discussion representative Solen um
having left things somewhat up in the
air when we left I just want to update
as we come back that our caucus is uh
prepared to go forward with a vote on
this all right thank you uh before we do
anything from other members seeing none
madame clerk could you
please take the
role uh this is a vote on
2023-24 04h the amendment to Bill
182 Vice chair
seaworth yes rep avalani yes rep Prout
yes rep love yes rep Boyd yes rep Cole
yes rep Co
yes rep dgo yes rep Granger yes ranking
them Sullivan yes rep Bary yes rep
kahill yes rep D sylvestro yes rep Susi
yes rep brard yes rep McKenzie yes the
clerk votes yes rep lir yes rep stab yes
Mr
chair yes that is 20 to zero
any objection to placing this on the
consent calendar we need to vote on the
bill oh oh we only amended I'm sorry I
got ahead of myself uh any further
discussion before we vote on the bill as
amended um please call the role on the
vote of
otpa oh we need the
motion I'm sorry see this is why this is
why they pay you the big Bo
uh is there a motion uh representative
you are
recognized thank you Mr chairman I move
otpa on House Bill 182
second moved and seconded now any
discussion and seeing none can we take
the
vote
um vote
otpa Vice chair seaworth yes rep avalani
yes rep Prout yes rep love yes rep Boyd
yes rep Cole yes rep KC yes rep drgo yes
rep Granger
no ranking D Sullivan yes rep barudi yes
rep kill yes rep D sylvestro rep Susi
yes rep buard yes rep McKenzie yes the
clerk votes yes repair yes rep stab yes
Mr chair yes that is 19 to Z I mean one
is there an objection to placing the
bill on consent no so we'll place the
bill on consent and I will turn the
Gabel back over to your capable hands
thank you Mr Vice chairman next bill um
House Bill 232 FN adopting uh section
1910 of the ocean standards uh prior to
any discussion representative Sullivan
and I have been made aware of something
and um we'd like to address it with the
Department if you wouldn't mind please
coming up to the podium again
representative
sol2 232 FM
thank you recognizing me yes I have okay
um it was pointed out to us that um we
still have a 60-day um uh um
implementation period for um for this
bill
and the concern was that on line six of
the amendment of the amendment um it
indicates employers shall provide
employees at least the level of
protection um provided under the federal
occupation safety and health
administration standards found in 29 CFR
part 1910
um if that language is in
there
would um the department have to start
enforcing um standards that are at least
effective within 60 days my sense was
that the department would start writing
rules
anytime after 60 days and within three
years um but it
do
you it seems to me there might be a
problem with that language does it seem
to be a problem to you as well uh so yes
representative I think I would agree
that there could be an interpretive
problem in How It Was Written and that's
a a good call on that um I think the
intent as you stated really was for us
to begin drafting rules and to put
stakeholders on notice that you know
they will be required to provide what's
at least as is effective um but um but
yes as the as it's technically written I
I think it would be correct to state
that the employers 60 days upon Passage
would be required to provide that level
of safety um I would State though that
you know as we kind of discussed
throughout uh the multiple years of
committees that we've dealt with this
you know the department would be working
with those employers um it wouldn't be
punitive um of course that's uh that's
not within the the actual statute at
that point so I would say I it's a
well-founded concern um but you know the
intent we would always have and have had
since we've been discussing this is to
go in do the best we can in the interim
before the rules are drafted to do these
pencil Audits and determine where these
uh public employers are at relative to
the 1910s and where we think they might
need to
be Mr Speaker
speaker
really we did need one for Mr chairman
works thank you
um having come this far with this it
might be a good idea to get it right
rather than close to right um so um I
would propose Mr chairman that um we um
do get a further adjustment of this
amendment um that would
um that would indicate the rule making
could begin 60 days after passage
um but there would be a three-year
period to complete that process um and
that uh we just make it clear that until
the rules are written you're not
enforcing the
rule so what do you say Mr chairman I
say you have uh until uh um Tuesday uh
next Thursday at 2
p.m where we will reconvene this
committee to deal with any business that
we did not finish
today including
this representative
k um thank you Mr chair I just I
wondered if because this is now now just
recently identified and something that
could be fairly straightforward in
remedying could this be done with a
floor Amendment rather than having us
reconvene on
Thursday
you know I it technically it could I
just I don't want it to bring
fodder um for a lot of things
um I will tell you I'll be honest with
you I think because we're meeting here
today people are starting to look at
these things and there might be another
sentence or two that who knows uh might
come to our
attention um so um we we have the time
uh we're doing this early enough before
our
deadline um whether we all agree on the
final thing or not it's not because a
lot of people didn't spend a lot of time
to try to get it
right see you next Thursday all right
representative Sullivan excuse me
seaworth thank you Mr chairman I just
wanted to point out to the members of
the committee if you didn't notice I set
another amendment to this bill in front
of you um won't discuss at at length but
it's essentially the option three that I
understand that uh was discussed before
the committee uh Mr chairman um so
that's something that hopefully you'll
have some more time to be able to review
it uh before we discuss it again thank
you so I am closing the hearing on um
House Bill 232 recessing the hearing on
232 FN uh to uh uh I will say right now
uh I'm I'm not going to give a date
certain because I got to make sure the
room's available and everything else but
is my brothers that the date certain
will be next Thursday at 2m
here Mr chairman um it occurs to me that
uh it is Thursday at 3 o' and the
calendar uh is already closed okay let's
pull out the
calendars and look pred yet the 17 well
let's look at the calendar let's take
we're taking the time to do this so
let's just look at
it today is the 2nd we have till Friday
the 17th we can uh meet next week we can
meet the following week uh on the
16th um it is uh and that will make the
calendar if that
makes um I think it has to be in the
calendar representative avalani pointed
out that if we continue this executive
session to a date certain you should put
your
on thank you if we can continue this
executive session to a date certain then
it has already been
noticed in that way but I'm not sure
about
the all the
details necessary to do
that I am going to
um I want to get this right guys does
anyone mind if I uh if everyone stays in
their seats and I recess a minute I'd
like to talk to the clerk yes
please
representative Sullivan members of the
committee I've spoken to the clerk and
we would have to uh it would have to be
scheduled in the calendar however the
calendar is not done and if you give me
five or 10 minutes I can ask Jamie to do
this and we should be all set for next
Thursday if that's acceptable all right
so everyone can check
there
all right uh it is being submitted to
the clerk so we should be all
set I'm not going to do anything with it
now moved let's moved our our last bill
and again there's an amendment here and
I apologize for the
late um present presentation of it House
Bill
82 FN relative to employment protection
for participation in therapetic
therapeutic cannabis
program i' like to make a motion
representative Granger I'd Like to Move
itl Motion on the floor is itl is there
a
second second by represent drgo is uh
you may speak to your
motion it seems to me that uh employees
and employer should have the same set of
Rights um I had I enjoy the ability to
so I have European co-workers that don't
have this uh but I can quit my job
whenever I want I can just stop showing
up it doesn't matter what my reason is
it doesn't matter why it could be
because I found a better opportunity it
could be a horrible reason it could be
simply I don't like my boss's sweater it
doesn't matter what the reason is it
doesn't need to be just it doesn't need
to be fair because I can make my own
decisions and if I make a bad decision
if I uh leave a job that was a good job
for a dumb reason I I suffer the
consequences I no longer have that job I
no longer have that income Source rights
aren't this sort of thing that apply to
some people but not others and that you
can exercise them when it's convenient
and not when it's not convenient if if
an employee or a company wants to fire
someone for any reason no matter what
they should have the same rights as the
employee does and if they lose a
valuable employee just because they had
a medic medical cannabis card then
that's their loss and yeah it's the
employees loss too but if I quit my job
that's the employer's loss
you can't be forcing people to comply to
our idea of what is right and what is
wrong we have to let people have rights
and get let them keep their rights and
that implies whether you like the
employer whether you dislike the
employer you got to let people do what
they do and they're never going to do
everything you want them to do they're
always going to do what they want to do
you got to have to live with
that representative uh representative
seaworth thank you Mr chairman uh
whatever parts of that AR argument I
agree with um I'd like to ask the
committee to please vote against this
motion um I think what we heard when
this bill was presented at least what
made the biggest impact on me is that
the New Hampshire Supreme Court has
um made a ruling on this issue and I
believe that if we can get to my
Amendment it will address exactly what
was in that ruling thank you
seeing no other hands there's a motion
on the floor of an exped to legislate
it's been moved seconded there been
discussion uh if you are in favor you'll
voting yes if you are against you'll be
voting nay Madam clerk please call the
RO an itl for Bill
82 Vice chair seaworth
no rip
alalani no
rep Prout no rep love no rep Boyd
no rep Cole no rep
kcom
no rep drgo yes rep gringer
yes ranking Dem Sullivan no rep berui no
rep kahill no rep d
sylvestro rep
Susi R Bard no R McKenzie
no the clerk votes no rep lir
no rep stab no Mr chair
no so that's 2 to 18 the
motion it is okay prior to making U
um asking for the next
motion representative s and I have
always agreed
that if we have competing
amendments uh we will make our case for
each one if each one does not pass
because it's a 1010 so be it and then
we'll deal with it as we do on the house
floor and everything else so I just want
everyone to understand what what is most
likely going to happen Okay uh before I
even call for motions representative
Sullivan you have a
question so I just want to understand
what the competing amendments are uh it
is uh the amendment by rep kcom and the
amendment by rep seaworth is what we're
talking about the amendment from
representative seaworth has am number
d245 and I am not exactly sure which
amendment you're going to present
whether it is the um uh Adent Amendment
or the uh sponsor amendment I I would
point out the Adent U Amendment has
already passed so that's that is what we
are sitting on right now um OTP as
amended that amendment was passed at
0785 it was passed on a 15 to5
vote I believe I I trying
to we have trouble remembering things
sometimes Mr chair could we repeat that
amendment number please Amendment
0785 h i i p it
here on the then we retained it it
was was a long
remember
H representative alalani thank you that
was presented by representative
Bale okay oh right
yes correct and that I do remember
correct yes but but you said it was the
addent amendment and that's what I
confused me it is the
that is not the same number make sure
we're getting all the right piece of
paper here oh folks you guys are all set
I'm sorry you
you we're done with the the oce Bill
thank you very much for coming I
apologize I'm
sorry okay does everyone have all their
binders they're pulling all this
out my
van whever it is
so some it's a different number I don't
know if
somebody I
don't I don't know where my
folder I have my own papers in my
my
mechan
work on further
Amendment we'll figure it
out yeah we did just folks it's been a
long time since we did this if you
recall what what occurred uh
representative go ahead representative
seaworth you can you just outlined it
better than I'm going to right now and
then representative Sullivan you can
opine all right so when this bill was
brought to us in the public hearing the
sponsor had already a draft drafted an
amendment to the original language said
that I have problems with my language is
drafted here's a substitute when we
first met an executive session we agreed
by a a margin to adopt that proposed
amendment and then we began I don't
remember I think we didn't have anything
else we then started talking about OTP
and we couldn't agree that that language
was the final product so we ended up um
not voting on
OTP some other amendments were brought
forth and when then we voted to retain
the bill to work on the language of the
those Amendment amendments so we were
left with the what's labeled as the veil
Amendment as having been ad replacing
the original language
um and that's how it has stayed and and
I would only add that the correct number
on the veil amendment is 0549 H cop of
this
am I think we should since most people
are not remembering
representative
alalani thank you Mr chairman there was
uh two that were brought forward one was
on February 15th which was 0549 by
representative B and also 0785 which was
brought forward on March 7th uh March
7th is the one that we took the vote on
um the 549 um did not come because it
had the did not have the exemptions in
section three uh for the public in
emergency
officials thank you that that's the
number I've got on my notes so I agree
that that's one we pass I simply don't
have that Amendment well we're going to
the clerk here is uh was quick enough to
go get the file and is going to have
copies made copies are being made of
07858 which um is listed as
the I think the agitant
amendment is it that or is it the
bail I think he made the
motion oh that might be right he did
second it anyway we'll have we'll have
it on the amendment he bring all of his
copies and then we pause
the
you weird say oh God pass that
voted it was 10 to okay let's
go just just for the sake of clarity um
each one of these amendments is
replacing section one so the last
amendment that we pass that replaces
section one is the amendment we
adopt I'm G to have theer I'm going to
have the clerk kind of go through it for
everyone as to what we did and then
we'll have the amendment and so you'll
see it if you have the original bill
with you so Madam clerk thank you Mr
chair so the order of business from
March 15 2023 I'm sure we've all
memorize this ha um the first motion was
moved by rep Sullivan seconded by rep
agitant for Amendment 2023
d07
85h and our vote on the amendment was
15-5 then rep Sullivan moved ought to
pass with amendment seconded by rep Susi
the vote was 10
to1 and then a motion was made by rep
Susi to retain this bill HB 82 that was
seconded by rep Sullivan with a vote of
16 to4 and that's what we arrive here
today to
complete
matter made
feel folks look at this if they want no
I have all
this all right I just want to get
everyone to get a copy of the amendment
so we can refresh everyone's memory and
move
forward now just the the amendment that
we passed in my recollection the change
um was to exclude emergency Personnel
fire and police correct Public Safety
the section
three this 0785 is the one that we
passed I'm sorry okay I don't have it in
front of me
it everyone kind of sorry for the new
people represent stab and Cole
um we get those amendments to
you
probably still have
cop this is the veil yes wrong one this
is the one we passed no it's
not says I'm sorry I'm sorry you're
right okay
yep
so hopefully if you have your original
bill in front of you and then the uh
Veil Amendment 0785
H that is where the bill this is where
the the legislation stands now because
this amendment was passed by this
committee prior to it being
retained
no I'm being told
no
not changes okay the first time this has
happened to me in 20 years 18 years so
representative Sullivan did you hear
what sh all right we uh explained that a
motion the bill was on excuse me the
bill was passed with Amendment
07858 however as soon as the bill was
retained that wiped out any amend
amendments they can still be
presented so we are now looking at um
the original bill doesn't mean that it
can't be presented
again all right so we're back to the
bill as
is I did I didn't know that new new one
on me is everyone all set with what
we're
doing don't have to
consider well um you know
it's put this way um representative
Sullivan uh we will be submitting one
Amendment would you like to uh look
through your amendments and determine if
how many if all if um or which one so we
can make sure everyone has
that
okay okay all right I think you
might um all right so what we have
potential is there are three amendments
that were were presented to the
committee uh prior to uh the bill being
retained we have one being presented
today representative Sullivan has uh
allowed me to allow to make a motion to
um or to hear a motion for the amendment
which representative seaworth will be
provided and at that point after hearing
it they'll make the decision whether or
not there will be any um additional
amendments on their side so being there
he is I am being the way it is I will
accept a motion representative seaworth
you are recognized for a motion thank
you uh Mr chairman I would move
Amendment 2023
245h second motion is made seconded by
represent balani you are recognized to
speak to your motion um thank you very
much and once again I want to apologize
for the late arrival I just got the
language last night um but I I put this
amendment together uh it goes back to a
concern that I had when the bill was
first presented in this committee and it
was discussed that the language came
from a New Jersey Law And it sort of
bothered me that um these things tie
into other laws within labor maybe other
laws outside of Labor and I don't know
New Jersey Law and I wondered if there
was some kind of connection that I
didn't understand so in putting together
this
amendment I wanted to tie it very
specifically to New Hampshire law and
very specifically to the New Hampshire
Supreme Court case that actually has
created what we understood from um the
the public testimony the status quo of
the law on this
issue
um
so much of this is is Tak taken directly
from the Supreme Court's opinion um the
Supreme Court said that uh at issue in
the case before them was the disability
of the employee who had been
dismissed and that
the marijuana card and and the status as
a marijuana user was
not the key point in why he should
wouldn't have been dismissed it was the
fact that he had a disability which is
protected under um RSA 354 D2 as
referenced in this
law
and so therefore if you uh review the
language that I have it ties it to that
connection um and then also makes clear
that the the person who has a
therapeutic
cannabis uh
card is presumed to have the disability
as protected under our existing statute
it also um covers the issue that we had
talked about before where
um this is not meant to authorize a
person
using
cannabis and being impaired by cannabis
on the job uh there is a presumption
that that is an undue hardship again
referring to uh the language in
35482 thank you I'm going to take the
liberty of of making a comment here and
then I'd like uh to recognize
representative proud one of the issues
that I had with the initial bill
was that I felt it went beyond in
current
employees to Future potential applicants
and
employees and representative s and I
agreed to disagree on that matter he
wanted it in there and I did not want it
in there but thanks to representative
Prout and I and representative kcom
going through all of the equal
opportunity section 354 A7 and
everything else that is already in
current law that you cannot discriminate
against future
employees so that's no longer a concern
of mine representative Prout you want to
expand on
this thank you um I think the SE withth
Amendment really um dovetails nicely
into our existing statutes um and it
creates the presumption is if you have a
card you have a qualifying disability
and then the entire body of law around
disabilities and how to handle them and
how to balance the rights of the
employee versus the needs of the
employer is just Incorporated and that's
been well litigated and I think the big
benefit we get from incorporating all of
that history is that there's a lot of
certainty about how things are supposed
to work and with that certainty brings
less cases going to court brings
everybody being certain of what they can
where they stand what they're supposed
to do what they can ask of employer what
they can't ask the employer and
basically in a and to cut it all short
reduces lawyer fees is less of these
cases will have to go to the lawyers to
the Department of Labor to the courts
and that it will essentially be both
faster and cheaper to get a resolution
for all involved when these cases come
forward and that's really one of the
benefits I see of dub tailing it into
the existing New Hampshire law and
everything that goes with
that
thank
you part of the Equal
Opportunity statute 354
A7
um uses the word qualified medical
condition and under the Equal
Opportunity uh employment opportunity
you cannot deny
um the ability of someone to have
um or to to make um it's the word I'm
looking for reasonable reasonable
accommodations thank you uh for someone
with a qualified medical condition
whether they're a current
employee or a potential
applicant
I was solid I'm sorry Mr chairman um the
um seeing how this is language is just
coming before us right
now um I feel compelled to have a I I
just feel compelled to have a quick
caucus to to discuss it as a group um so
that hopefully we can move forward today
with uh
something yes and if you can't let me
know as soon as possible so I can get
one more thing on
Thursday
all right we're we're back I will um uh
outline that uh remember of the public
Who's involved with the um cannabis
program um who's been forced a number of
times does not know whether this is an
issue but line three it the the
technical term under 126x is qualifying
patient not qualified
patient we will look into that and if we
do have to make an amendment on the
floor or something simple is that's is
that
acceptable all right so we're we're back
from I unfortunately I got it out of the
old yep Bill not okay I see I see where
you got it yeah well we'll check with
see how this goes first then we can
always check uh representative Sullivan
uh you're um you're recognized to
speak I I I'm going to vote in favor
this amendment and in favor of ought to
pass as amended um and I guess I just
appreciate the uh um the hard work and
study that uh uh some of my colleagues
here have put into this and I think it
uh it accomplishes and I I he I heard
one of the comments that this is going
to save a lot of legal fees that is true
and there's no sense in uh um dragging
more people um through the court system
in order to get what they're they ought
to be in entitled to so um I just want
to say thank you for the amendment it it
does what uh I believe is
needed thank you I also appreciate all
the people that dug into this
um so thank you very much are there any
other comments uh from any other members
of the committee prior to taking a vote
we have a motion we have a um motion uh
motion for an amendment it's been
seconded and it's been
discussion if you're in favor you'll
vote Yes oppos vote
no Madam clerk
yes this is a a vote on Amendment
2023-24
5H Vice chair seaworth yes rep avalani
yes rep prep yes rep love yes rep Boyd
yes rep Cole yes rep hulc yes rep drgo
yes rep Granger yes rep uh ranking Dam
Sullivan yes rep buudy rep kahill rep D
sylvestro yes rep Susy yes R Bard yes R
McKenzie yes the clerk votes yes R
mclair yes rep stab yes Mr chair yes 20
to
zero uh the the the mo uh the amendment
is passed is open for further Amendment
representative
seaworth um
I would like to move on to pass as with
the amendment all right that's an
appropriate uh motion as well is that
seconded by representative avalani is
open for
discussion seeing not the motion on the
pass motion the floor is out to pass
with the amendment they vote yeah yes if
you're I'm sorry representative seaworth
a to pass the
amendment it's all right I understand it
pass second by repr
avalani you're in favor you vote Yes
against vote no Madam
clerk Vice chair seaworth
yes rep avalani yes rep Prout yes rep
love yes rep Boyd yes rep Cole yes rep
kulum yes rep drgo no rep Granger no
ranking down Sullivan yes rep buudy yes
rep kahill yes rep D sylvestro rep Susi
yes R Bard yes R McKenzie yes the clerk
votes yes rep Clair yes rep stab yes and
Mr chair yes
18-2 any objection to consent agenda if
you do you just have to write the
minority
blur
should I do the the Jeopardy
Tong you're all set all right no
objection
consent all right uh there's no further
um uh bills in front of us I will let
you know that I'm expecting about 12 to
14 pieces of legislation coming to us uh
have not been able to read all the
things they're just titles so I just
made a guess um and that um
our goal is to meet I believe it's the
18th and 25th of January to discuss uh
you know as many bills as possible I'd
like to have all of our bills heard
within three three days three Thursdays
so then we can dig into what we have and
again I don't know all of it
representative McKenzie has a few that
he shared with me I haven't really seen
the wording yet but we'll wait and see
some of them will be quick some of them
will require Sub sub
committees
represent San do you have any comments
uh or any announcements no announcements
but a comment um it seems that when we
sit in partisan grouping we do our most
bipartisan work so I I don't I don't get
it but it
is May than well I will take it as um
digging into it deep and trying to find
where we can make a compromise so thank
you very much everyone any questions of
the share No seeing none thank you very
much we'll see you all next Thursday
good luck on your election oh I'm not
going to win I don't want to win oh I on
the ballot Myself by accident long
story